[Music]
hi I'm Jennifer Evans Carrio president
of sugar spun marketing author of
Pinterest marketing an hour a day in the
social media faculty chair at market
motive thanks for joining me for part 4
and the wrap-up in our series on
Facebook marketing one of the biggest
problems with social media from the
perspective of the user is that there
are so many different sites out there
that it's absolutely ridiculous
no one can stay on top of all of them
managing your login at multiple
locations and even figuring out how they
all work together is darn near
impossible one of the more brilliant
moves that Facebook has had in its
history is the idea of Facebook Connect
basically what Facebook Connect lets you
do is use Facebook's API and the
knowledge that the greatest majority of
human beings that are online are using
Facebook and it allows them to use their
facebook login as their login for
whatever website interface or program
you set up so whereas before people
would go to Facebook go to a brand page
then potentially come back around to
Facebook to do the sharing it allows
people to go directly to a brand or
directly to a resource or a website and
well on that website interact with their
Facebook account so it basically cut to
step out of the equation which makes it
far more likely that is people engage
with their brand that engagement that
interaction will actually show up on
Facebook published to their streams and
reach their friends and family now the
basic way of how it works is fairly
simple
you're integrating Facebook's like
button or a variety of other Facebook
options right into the content on your
website so for example here we have a
story from Mashable and at the top it
says do you like the story and if you
click that like button it's going to pop
up a little option that you can either
just go with hey I liked this or you can
actually add some content to the mix you
know give it your own description and
post it to your Facebook page and when
you push that post a Facebook button
it's going to show up there right in
your Facebook stream it's going to
publish out for everyone that you're
connected with and again from
at base website that the user was
choosing to interact with they can very
quickly and easily publish things out to
their Facebook feed and get it into the
news stream the reality is there's quite
a few social plug in options using
Facebook Connect a couple of the more
popular ones the like button you'll see
this popping up all over the web you'll
see it on ecommerce sites on content
sites pretty much everywhere is that
ubiquitous little Facebook like buttons
that people click and as soon as they
click it it broadcasts out to their
network hey this is content that these
people actually like there's also the
send button where the share button
depending on how long ago it's been
implemented it can actually pop up
either way this one you'll see often
times showing up alongside content or
videos sometimes on e-commerce sites but
usually it's content and video focus and
this basically lets you take the content
that you see and send it to Facebook
send it to a group send it to someone
that you're connected with but basically
not just share it to your wall but
actually send it through to specific
people that you're connected with on
Facebook there's also a comments plug-in
that basically allows anyone that has a
blog or again even an e-commerce site to
integrate comments from Facebook right
there into their page so you can be
reading someone's blog post and at the
end of the blog post you're going to see
that add a comment button and it's going
to show you logged into your Facebook
account because your Facebook account
will basically follow you all over the
web unless you have your cookies turned
off so this gives you the opportunity to
have those comments taking place on your
site but to also have it publishing back
to Facebook because as that happens say
when Katie asked and makes a post using
her Facebook commenting it then
publishes out and her friend Rita
McCartin is going to see it on Facebook
and can click into the website read the
post and then once again leave a comment
that can turn around and publish out to
somebody else there's also the idea of
the Facebook Activity Feed this
basically shows up on your content site
it lets a person who comes to your site
see which of the people they're
connected with have liked this page and
sometimes it will even show
the people that they're connected with
that have liked a specific page shared a
specific page commented on a page
basically lets you see which friends
have been active on a site and what
they're doing and then finally the idea
of the registration integration and this
is what we talked about a couple slides
ago the idea that you can use your
facebook login to connect to a new
website and to basically run your
profile on that site so Pinterest one of
the many many examples of companies that
will just let you sign in with your
Facebook account without creating any
new registration information once you
connect with some of these sites using
your Facebook account the great thing
about it you then have access to your
friends from within Facebook so example
if you're on a site like Pinterest and
you're looking to connect with more
friends on the site it's a great way to
go through and say well which of my
facebook friends are also on Pinterest
so I can come through and follow them or
which of my facebook friends are also on
Instagram or on Twitter so that I can
connect with them and follow them now
the developers page at Facebook does
keep a running tab of all of the social
plugins that are available gives you a
great walkthrough of what they are how
they work and will also help you
generate the code that you need to plug
into your web page in order to integrate
these different options so you can read
to that at developers facebook.com slash
Doc's slash plugins now the
possibilities using Facebook Connect are
pretty expensive
think from the social gaming platform
you know think how big social gaming is
on Facebook or on mobile apps the fact
that you can connect it to a user's
Facebook account and publish updates to
their games and they've reached
such-and-such level or you know they
just scored how many points and words
with friends all of it gives you the
opportunity to tie interactivity with
your brand into the Facebook page of the
person that you're dealing with so that
again you get some of that social
sharing promotion and marketing effort
also the ability to have some friend
integration you know pulling in the
profile the pictures the contact
information so think of the example I
showed from Pinterest where you can
actually go in and see which of your
friends are also using Pinterest so that
you're able to connect with them voting
systems can come into play here you know
basically you can bring people in for
polls that say you know hey come and
share your opinion on this you
vote on this idea or this concept and
have it connect back to their Facebook
account so that they can then encourage
their friends and family to come in and
vote you know or have have their say on
a specific topic and then the same thing
with forums it gives people the
opportunity to connect with their
Facebook friends because they may not
have realized that people they were
friends with on Facebook we're also
present on this forum or this website or
in this discussion area so having that
tie-in helps people see those social
connections taking place all over the
web and really maximize the ability to
interact with the people that they care
about now another aspect of Facebook
that needs to be considered is the idea
of check-ins you know a few years back
check-ins were starting to run really
well on things like koala and Foursquare
but his Facebook introduced Facebook
places and started encouraging people to
check in as part of their status updates
we definitely saw some changes in that 1
in 5 smartphone users checks in each
month using some type of location-based
service Facebook continues to steal
market share from Foursquare and Gowalla
because again there's no need to go use
another service if you're already using
Facebook regularly anyways now the
demographics on smartphones sharing and
the social check-ins that tends to be
people who are in the younger age group
so between 25 and 34 mostly full-time
workers people who are out of college
and professionally and gainfully
employed these are the people that tend
to utilize that activity the most so if
you have a brick and mortar store if you
are doing some type of event if this is
your target market you want to make sure
that you're doing something to help
motivate those check-ins motivate that
sharing so that it will broadcast out to
the rest of their network of course in
order to check into a place you actually
have to have a place listing on Facebook
now for the most part Facebook will
actually go through sort of the yellow
page listings you know or the Google
Places listing and they'll pull business
names and addresses and phone numbers
and general basic information and
they'll do their best based on
geolocation to actually pop that up as
an option for people when they check in
what will work much better for you is if
you actually take that Places listing
and you combine it with the Facebook
page for your brick-and-mortar business
so if you go and you run a search for
your company name and you see if you can
locate it if it is still showing up with
just the generalized little location dot
and it's not your Facebook business page
then you need to look over in the Edit
area for the option to claimant B do you
know the owner is this your business you
create a page this gives you the chance
to take that existing listing and either
turn it into a full-fledged page or
merge it with the existing page that you
have so if you check that hole is this
your business they're going to basically
take you through a verification process
it's going to require phone or document
verification just prove you are who you
say you are then they'll give you the
ability to merge it in with the official
Facebook page that you've created for
this business so that way when people
check in and their friends see it if
they happen to click on say the Carleton
Motel will actually take them to the
Facebook page for the Carlton Hotel
rather than just the standard listing
now this can also work really well for
events because if you're promoting
events you're setting them up on
Facebook you're inviting people in to
RSVP for them if they have RSVP'd for an
event they can also then check in to
that event when they actually show up at
it because it will have the address the
location everything will be tied back in
so it's a great way to encourage your
followers to connect with you you know a
lot of e-commerce companies and a lot of
brick-and-mortar stores are using it for
special events or for you know previews
of new items and clothing that are
coming out but they're even also using
it just for sales to say hey here's this
big sale that we have going on here's
what we're going to have for offer you
can discuss what your strategy is
men and jobbing you can post pictures
about what's going to be going on it's
basically just another way to get the
buzz in the conversation going on
Facebook about what's going on in your
store now when it comes to Facebook a
lot of companies have a hard time trying
to figure out okay how do we get rolling
you know what's our priority need to be
do we just get in and start posting do
we need to spend a bunch of time
observing how does this work so a good
rule of thumb is when you start you had
to build a page because if you don't
have a page nobody's going to show up
nobody has a way to connect with you so
even if you don't put a ton of content
on it yet get some type of basic level
presence up and running look at what
your cover photo is look at what your
content is going to be and then start to
create a Content plan you know figure
out what do you want to put out there
what do you think is going to be a good
fit for your target market that's when
you want to start soliciting followers
so you may decide to do that through
some advertising and some paid and
sponsored posts you may decide to do it
via some of your other channels maybe
your blog or your Twitter feed maybe you
want to put fliers in the bag of every
person who comes in and shops at your
store but basically you have to start
soliciting some followers then you want
to start offering content to those
followers and you want to start looking
at which pieces of content they're
interacting with you know how is your
EdgeRank doing how much exposure and how
much virality are you getting from the
content you're putting out there and
then interact with them you know don't
just put up the content let them respond
and do nothing if people are responding
to you respond back and engage them in
conversation thank you so much for
joining me for this series on Facebook
marketing
hey once you become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simple
learned Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here